in the past couple of decades the status
of women in indian society has changed
drastically at present women play a
crucial role in the growth of the indian
economy and have made a big impact and
achieve success in almost every sector
in this video we will talk about the top
five famous women entrepreneurs who have
done something different to boost the
indian economy and inspire women's
society the number one on our list is
falguni nair she has been the talk of
the town since nika's recent listing on
the stock market she is one of the 24
women globally whose business touched
the ipo milestone she's an indian
businesswoman and self-made billionaire
who is the founder and ceo of the beauty
and lifestyle retail company naika
naira's journey as an entrepreneur
started in 2012
after serving 20 years as a venture
investor and merchant with kotak
mahindra she suddenly announced her
departure to pursue her dream at 50. she
founded the e-commerce brand naika the
company became a hit in the market
making falguni naya one of the
wealthiest business women in india nika
became the frontrunner in bringing
internationally luxury brands to india
giving indian customers all encompassing
products and services to choose from the
following success of naya's startup made
her india's wealthiest self-made women
billionaire with an estimated net worth
of 6.5 billion dollars
she is a true inspiration to all women
who want to follow their dreams
at the second spot we have vandana
luthra
vanara luthra the founder of vlcc had
perfectly understood the need among the
people who go to great lengths to
maintain their beauty this feat earned
her recognition in india's business
sphere she started vlcc a beauty and
wireless conglomerate in 1989 which went
on to produce formidable success soon
after a lot of hard work and struggles
vlcc became a globally recognized name
in their beauty health and fitness
industry soon vandana luthra became one
of the country's top women entrepreneurs
winning several awards such as the
padmashree in 2013 by the government of
india the woman entrepreneur of the year
award in 2010 the rajiv gandhi award in
2008 and many more she was also featured
in fortune magazine's annual listing of
the 50 most powerful women in business
in india for six years in a row from
2011 to 2016. she is properly referred
to as the queen of wellness and became
an inspiration for many homemakers after
her successful venture at number 3 we
have kiran mazumdar shah
she is the founder chairman and managing
director of biocon limited kieran shaw
was born and brought up in bangalore
where she completed her bachelors in
bangalore university
then she went on to do her master's from
melbourne university her story of
starting biocoin india in 1978 out of
the garage in bengaluru has been an
inspiration for many young women she
faced multiple hurdles on the way
starting with a lack of capital to the
challenge of finding qualified workers
however her journey made the difference
in changing lives for the better across
the globe under her backing biocon
delivers on the promise of making
medicines accessible and affordable to
millions of patients worldwide today
biocon india is one of the leading
players in the biomedicine research
space
biocon's profits increased rapidly and
karen shaw became india's wealthiest
self-made woman and her current network
is 3.5 billion dollars according to
forbes she is the recipient of several
awards and accolades including the
prestigious padmashree in 1989 the padma
bhushan in 2005 the utmo gold medal in
2014 and many more at fourth spot we
have indra nui indra novi was born and
brought up in chennai she did a
bachelors in science from madras
christian college in 1974. later she did
a masters in public management from yale
university and a masters in finance and
marketing from iim kolkata she started
as a product manager at johnson and
johnson she later held important
positions at many companies including
motorola and scr brown bubery newey
joined pepsico as senior vice president
of corporate strategy and development in
1994 with the intellect and hard work
she assumed the title of ceo in 2016
and right after that year she became the
chairman of the book
nui was the fifth chairman and ceo of
pepsico's 42 year history and she was
the first ever woman to lead the soft
drink and snack food giant under her
leadership the company's revenue shot
from 35 billion dollars to 63.5 billion
dollars in just one year she was also
awarded the prestigious partner bhushan
for her business achievements this
incredible mind retired from the
position in 2019 and joined amazon.com
as a member of the audit committee at
the board of directors of amazon she has
truly been an inspiration to all of
women kind last but not least we have
aditi gupta in the fifth spot aditi
gupta is an author and co-founder of
menstrupedia this social entrepreneur
was born in jharkhand india to a strict
and orthodox family where people
consider menstruation as a sin
these things confused her until she met
her business come life partner mr tuheen
paul in college disturbed by society's
attitude they wish to educate the masses
they found a severe lack of awareness
about menstruation even among educated
people and this motivated them to
develop the website menstropedia it
provides a user-friendly guide to
menstruation hygiene and puberty while
breaking the myths associated with them
in 2014 menstrual pedia partnered with
whisper india for the school contact
program and presented touch the pickle
which happened in four different cities
in 2014 the comic book she published
reached fame and was translated to
spanish and nepali the famous author
made it to the achievers forbes india 30
in 2014. this mind-blowing author uses
her storytelling skills to educate girls
about menstruation and inspires them to
create a future by understanding that
menstruation is not a prohibition but a
welcome change in women's lives as one
of india's young women entrepreneurs she
is the prominent face in her field that
brings us to the end of the video and of
course the list of successful women
entrepreneurs in india is endless and we
would like to know in the comments
section which woman inspired you the
most in your life thank you again for
watching this video and stay tuned for
more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here